está a un paso del inicio y como en 2017
se enfrenta en manual macrón marine
lepén de 53 años había considerado
terminar con la política después de su
fallido debate contra el candidato de la
república en marcha cinco años después
su presencia en la segunda ronda premia
su cambio de estrategia después de su
derrota en 2017 marie le pen decide
cambiar el nombre de frente nacional un
logo renovado nuevos ejecutivos más
jóvenes el objetivo mostrar una imagen
menos divisoria a la del partido que
dirigió su padre durante años enfrentada
a eric se mudó la candidata opta por
hacer lo contrario del ex periodista una
campaña menos mediática con más viajes
locales mientras este nuevo rival hace
campaña sobre los temas favoritos de la
agrupación nacional
ella elige sin renunciar a sus programas
anteriores no excederse y centrarse en
el poder adquisitivo
frente al bloque de élite frente a la
oligarquía encarnada por el manuel macro
nesta el pueblo y el pueblo superan en
número a la casta cuando estalló la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania marine
lepén optó por seguir a la opinión
pública se distanció de vladimir putin y
defendió la acogida de los refugiados
ucranianos hoy después de dos campañas
fallidas ella espera que este nuevo
enfoque la convierta en la próxima
presidenta de la república